[Applaudissements]
pauvre gosse naqui dans la misère
aussitôt on lui
demanda s'il voulait vivre avec sa mère
puisqu'il n'avait plus de papa c'était
un pauvre qui s'appelait Armand l'avait
pas de papa l'avait pas de maman son
père était mort à 13 ans un soir qu'il
jouait dans la neige avec un tout petit
serpent
quiavait pris pour une ASP c'était un
qui s'it
arm
papa sa mère qui avait la jaunice la ver
filé à son amant qui attendait le moment
prop pour la repasser à
[Musique]
Armand
la seule fille qui en fut amoureuse ne
savait que garder ses moutons
elle luiila la
fièvreteuse et c'est lui qui garda ses
boutons c'était un qui s'appelait
Armand
papa mais un jour pendant la
tté nounou un peu plate il lui souffla
dans les nénés jusqu'à ce que la nounou
éclate un qui
s'appitit pas de papait pas de maman un
qui
s'a PAP
[Musique]
MAM